a Washington Post columnist decides that
Hitler had a dog you have a dog
therefore you are Hitler James Comey
gets slapped by the Inspector General
and we'll check the mailbag I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
right so we got a lot to get to today
but before we get to any of it let me
remind you that this month is indeed
National Life Insurance Awareness Month
I know you would set them on the side to
celebrate that I know that you have big
plans for National Life Insurance
Awareness Month
but since I've mentioned it now twice
I've known in your head so now's a good
time for you to get life insurance
because here is the reality are you an
adult are you a responsible human being
make sure that your family is taken care
of in case you get hit by a bus in the
next ten minutes like go right now and
buy life insurance over at policy
genius.com right now is a great time to
buy life insurance it turns out because
prices are the lowest they have been in
20 years and policy genius has made it
easier than ever for you to get covered
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for life insurance online in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance policy genius makes
it super easy to do all this you don't
want to think about your impending doom
for the rest of the entire month or next
month or the month after that instead
what you should be doing is getting it
done right now then you never have to
think about this again until you plotz
at which point it won't help you to
think about it cuz you'll be dead but at
least your family will have the money
that they got from the life insurance
policy you were responsible responsible
enough to buy through policy genius.com
so head on over to policy genius com get
quotes apply in minutes you can do the
whole thing on your phone right now
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance alrighty so we
begin today with a quick recap of the
rise and fall of James Comey we have a
chance to do this on the podcast
yesterday because this news broke after
the podcast was over but here is the
story so James Comey former FBI director
hero of the Republic for a brief moment
in time brief shining moment in time
well the report came out yesterday from
the Office of the Inspector General over
at the DOJ and basically what it found
is that he leaked classified information
to the press through a friend
that wasn't heavily classified it wasn't
super duper top secret classified
it wasn't like he set up a private
server like Hillary Clinton or something
instead what happened is something
fairly simple he created a series of
memos he deletes those memos to one of
his friends who was outside the
government that person then proceeded to
hand those over to the New York Times
and that was in fact a violation of law
but not bad enough that he was actually
going to get prosecuted
now James Comey then declared himself
exonerated there are so many ironies in
this story it's like layer it's an onion
irony you take off that top layer
another layer of irony and then another
layer of it all the way down to that
core of granite iron irony it's just as
fantastic so James Comey was he started
off you'll recall as an enemy to the
Democrats right because in 2016
James Comey made the grave error of
going out in public and spilling on how
Hillary Clinton violated the law six
ways from Sunday and then he said but
we're not prosecuting her cuz I've
changed the law conveniently for her
I've changed the law now I'm rewriting
it she's not gonna be prosecuted but she
did some bad stuff guys some bad stuff
and Hillary Clinton campaign rightly
said well if you're not prosecuting me
then why are you spilling all his crap
out in public right now
irony layer number one the entire
Democratic Party was super happy that
robert muller then did the exact same
thing to donald trump on the Trump
Russia and obstruction of justice stuff
because that's what the Mullen report
was it was all the reasons why Trump is
bad also we're not prosecuting him but
here you are and just play vomit all
this material right out there in public
okay so James Comey did that in 2016 it
was very bad then the Democrats flipped
and by 2019 it was really good yes
that's irony number one then James Comey
right before the election reopens the
investigation into Hillary Clinton and
has to notify the entire world about it
like five days before the election and
then a couple days later he says oh yeah
by the way that we don't really find
anything and this really hurts Hillary
Clinton so he is the enemy right he's
the person who cost Hillary Clinton the
election supposedly then it turns out
that he's a hero of the Republic why
well because he started keeping tabs on
president Trump he was suspicious of
President Trump and because he was
suspicious of President Trump he started
keeping memos and he refused to just say
out loud what he'd already told Trump
which is that Trump wasn't under
investigation it turns out the reason he
wasn't saying that is could Trump was
kind of under investigation by Comey and
the FBI
the reason Comey was keeping memos was
presumably in order to provide the basis
for an obstruction
of Justice charge or in order to gather
information on Trump Russia kind of
stuff so Comey was either fibbing to
trump or he was unwilling to say
something that was eminently true to the
American public one of these two things
was obvious okay so he ends up getting
fired and now he's a hero of the
Republic again so he went from being
Democratic enemy to democratic hero
which in and of itself is a certain
level of irony especially because he
probably costs Hillary Clinton the
election in the view of Democrats okay
so for two years
he's hero of the Republic because he was
fired by Trump and this was obviously
Trump trying to stop the Russia
investigation then a couple things
happened one the Russia investigation
comes to nothing and two it turns out
that James Comey is in fact a leaker and
that he lied about leaking and the James
Comey is in fact a self aggrandizing
tool who is not very good at his job
which is unfortunate for James Comey not
great for James Comey and so the OIG
analysis comes out yesterday and James
Comey and another layer of irony then
declares himself exonerated this is the
same guy this is the same guy who
declared that President Trump was
supremely wrong for declaring himself
exonerated by the Mullah report so which
is it
well he wasn't exaggerated here okay not
only was he not exonerated the report is
pretty damning basically the OIG found
and this is a direct quote that
consistent with the Inspector General
acts and Department regulations this
matter was referred to the OIG in July
2017 by then acting FBI director Andrew
McCabe following the FBI's determination
that Comey may have shared memos that
contain classified information with his
personal attorneys and they say yes the
memos were number one FBI records so he
called them personal records they were
not they were FBI records second Comey
violated Department and FBI policies
pertaining to the retention handling and
dissemination of FBI records and
information they say commis actions with
respect to the memos violated Department
and FBI policies and then they say that
he failed to return memos after being
removed as FBI director he improperly
disclosed FBI documents and information
through a third party to a reporter they
say that he improperly disclosed the
presence of this information to his
attorneys in other words there are a
bevy of violations here they didn't rise
to the level of the criminally
prosecuted but he definitely violated a
bunch
internal FBI regulations his employment
agreement and all the rest and the OIG
concluded that commis behavior really
damaged the FBI they said quote the
responsibility to protect sensitive law
enforcement information Falls in large
part to the employees of the FBI who
have access to it through their daily
duties on occasion some of these
employees may disagree with decisions by
prosecutors judges or higher ranking FBI
and Department officials about the
actions to take or not take in criminal
and counterintelligence matters they may
even in some situations distrust the
legitimacy of those Supervisory
prosecutorial or judicial decisions but
even when these employees believe that
their most strongly held personal
convictions might be served by an
unauthorized disclosure the FBI depends
on them not to disclose sensitive
information former director Comey failed
to live up to this responsibility by not
safeguarding sensitive information
obtained during the course of his FBI
employment and by using it to create
public pressure for official action
Comey set a dangerous example for the
over 35,000 current FBI employees in the
many thousands more former FBI employees
who similarly have access to or
knowledge of non-public information
homie said he was compelled to take
these actions but it doesn't matter
because they have previously faulted
Comey for acting unilaterally and
inconsistent with department policy
commis unauthorized disclosure of
sensitive law enforcement information
about the Flynn investigation merits
similar criticism in a country built on
the rule of Lyman this is the OIG just
slap and call me across the grill in a
country built on the rule of law is of
the utmost importance that all FBI
employees adhere to Department and FBI
policies particularly when confronted by
what appeared to be extraordinary
circumstances or compelling personal
convictions Comey had several other
lawful options available to him to
advocate for the appointment of a
special counsel which he told us was his
goal in making the disclosure what was
not permitted was the unauthorized
disclosure of sensitive investigative
information obtained during the course
of FBI employment in order to achieve a
personally desired outcome hey the DOJ
declined to prosecute but that is bad
news for James Comey and it also does
speak to real questions that folks have
about the honesty and objectivity of the
FBI and there's just another black mark
for the FBI on the left the suggestion
was that the FBI went
for Hillary Clinton too hard on the
rights the suggestion is that the FBI
basically concocted the Trump Russia
investigation to go after the Trump
campaign under the Obama administration
and we still are awaiting an OIG report
about the origins of the Trump Russia
investigation there are two plausible
theories about the origins of the Trump
Russia investigation plausible theory
number one is that it was initiated in
good faith based on information received
by the FBI that there were several
low-level aides to the Trump campaign
who are meeting with Russian sources and
so they initiated the investigation and
then it's spun out of control that
confirmation bias people like Peter
struck and Lisa page at the FBI who
hated President Trump and who were
deeply suspicious of him they started to
find information where they were seeing
it I think they were just looking for
data and they found the data they were
looking for it didn't matter that they
were missing the entire forest they
spotted the trees that they wanted they
honed in on those trades right that is
theory number one initiated in good
faith but pursued wrongly Theory number
two was initiated always in bad faith
that basically the FBI received
information via the Hillary Clinton
campaign and then they initiated the
investigation based on a desire to harm
the Trump campaign and they were
planning to spring that on the Trump
campaign late in the campaign if they
thought that he was going to they
thought that he was going to win or post
campaign if he actually did win right
that is theory number two and we'll find
out which one of these is true what is
certainly true is that faith in the FBI
in the competence core competence of the
people at the highest level in the FBI
has to have been shaken by all of this I
mean James Comey was the head of the FBI
and it turns out that not only was he
incompetent he was happy to violate
departmental policy in order to in order
to pursue his own personal agenda which
is exactly the accusation that critics
of the FBI on the behalf of Trump are
making which is that the FBI is
sometimes politically driven by the way
the left has had similar criticisms of
the FBI going all the way back to the
FBI targeting Martin Luther King jr.
right so this is a bad time for the FBI
Andrew McCabe who is the acting FBI
director ends up getting fired for doing
the same thing he had leaked information
to the media that he thought would help
him and help his bosses in his job he
said that he did so at the behest of
James Comey Comey denied it so the
leadership of the FBI it has a real
problem and this is not good I mean if
we've been talking this whole week about
the undermining of faith and
institutions if people empower at
institutions do a crap job it turns out
that does a fairly solid job
undermining faith in those institutions
overall so that report very bad for Jim
James Comey naturally came out and said
well now I want an apology from dude
you're not getting an apology from
anyone just go take some more pictures
of yourself standing over vistas of
grain every day he's such a weird dude
like now Jim's commis entire job
consists of taking Instagram photos in
front of nature if you watch his Twitter
feed his entire Twitter feed is like him
staring up at a giant redwood or him
standing on a road well I guess he can
go be a nature photographer or something
because he's never going to get a job
anywhere near the intelligence community
ever again given his malfeasant here
okay meanwhile I have to comment on a
couple of pieces in the Washington Post
yesterday so apparently was my birthday
because the Washington Post decided to
run not one but two editorials targeting
me yesterday which is just a party
there's nothing I love better than just
sitting here doing my job and suddenly
there are a couple of op eds in the
Washington Post but thank you guys for
really you know making sure that my
exposure continues to grow so I
appreciate that
from the Washington Post we'll get to
that in just one second because not only
are there two op eds that were directed
against me they are both awful I mean
just objectively I'm gonna be trying to
be I know
look I'm invested in in this they're
attacking me but I'm pretty sure these
are bad op-eds I'll explain why in just
a moment first let's talk about how you
sleep better and so as I've told you
many times I am NOT good at sleeping I'm
good at some things I'm not good at
others Kent I don't have a good jump
shot I'm gonna talk not good at sleeping
okay so how can I make my sleep quality
better well I did this by going and
getting a helix sleep mattress the
beautiful thing about a helix sleep
mattress is that it is personalized to
you right that's quite wonderful that
means you take a two-minute sleep quiz
and they will match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on the side on your back hot sleep or
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep comm slash
men take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life when I'm on the road
I have a really tough time sleeping
because I'm away from my beloved helix
sleep mattress it's so good that I got
one for my sister and her husband upon
the occasion of their wedding for
couple's helix can even split that
mattress down the middle and that'll
give you the individual support knee
and feel preferences that you want for
each side you've got a ten year warranty
you try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will hilux is
offering right now up to 125 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 125 bucks off at helix sleep
comm / Ben again helix sleep comm / Ben
for up to 125 dollars off your mattress
order so solid deal risk-free go check
it out I promise it's gonna make your
life a whole hell of a lot better okay
so let's jump into these insane
editorials from the Washington Post so
this here herein lies the Washington
Post argument every one on the right is
Hitler everyone is Hitler and they will
make this argument till their face turns
blue it's one of the reasons why
President Trump is president is because
everybody who happens to be even
slightly right of center is tired sick
of tired of being labeled a white
supremacist they're tired of being
labeled racist they're tired of being
labeled all the bad words in the
universe simply because they disagree
with Nancy Pelosi on tax policy and
abortion and as we'll see the left
doesn't understand this so when people
like me say you know what why don't you
have a conversation with us because we
actually agree on white supremacy being
evil we all agree that Nazis suck we're
all on the same page here the first
response had left is ah but aren't you a
Nazi that's like god bless it you're
making my argument for me my whole
argument is that we are having a tough
time conversing with one another and
people are getting angry and they are
responding in dramatically reactionary
fashion because you keep calling them
something they are not if you keep
calling people Nazis eventually they
just throw up a giant middle finger and
the middle finger it has a giant T on it
right that's the Trump middle finger
that's what it was
right you you went at the right long
enough you kept calling us white
supremacist you kept calling us Nazis
and then Trump was out there basically
saying you're all Schmucks okay find
that guy do it hey
so the left's response to this is but
aren't you Nazis though aren't your
Nazis now here is the greatest example
of this I have ever seen so yesterday in
the Washington Post there's a piece by a
woman named Eva Fairbanks the piece is
titled the reasonable rebels
conservatives say we've abandoned reason
incivility the Old South used the same
language to
and slavery okay this is literally the
Hitler dog argument this is Hitler had a
dog you have a dog
thus by logical deduction you are Hitler
what the actual it turns out you know
who is called for reason and civility
like a lot of people over the course of
all of human history have called for
reason and civility and by the way I
would note that the Old South did not
make its bones on calling for reason and
civility
they made their bones on firing on Fort
Sumter for God's sake
they initiated the largest war in the
history of the United States ending with
the deaths of 600,000 people that was
not reason incivility also you know I
know that conservatives today are not
like the Old South when they call for
reason and civility because I'm not
whipping black folks while I'm calling
for reason incivility you because
I don't own slaves you dumbass like what
what are you what are you even talking
about this is it is exactly the Hitler
dog argument it is exactly the Hitler
dog argument right Hitler used to eat
vegetables do you eat vegetables do you
do you Hitler liked art do you like our
Hitler listen to classical music you
listen to classical music
you keep saying reason incivility you
know who else used to say reason
incivility
only difference between you and the
slaveholders is that they held slaves
yes that is a big difference that is a
very very large difference and so I'm
not exaggerating this is this is a very
very long piece making exactly this
argument you ready here it is after the
El Paso shooting Ben Shapiro a popular
conservative podcaster thank you very
much asked Americans to draw a line
between the few conservatives who are
white supremacists and those who like
him aren't first of all no I didn't ask
Americans to draw a line between the few
conservatives who are white supremacists
and those like me who I said that it is
non conservative by definition to be a
white supremacist because conservatism
is about values conservatism is about
the sacrosanct nature of the individual
conservatism is about judging
individuals as human beings it is not
about group identity that cuts directly
against conservatism okay so no you get
it wrong in the fur
and then it gets worse almost all
Americans are on the same side he said
and we should be mourning together in
his telling we aren't for one simple
reason too many on the political left
are castigating the character of those
who disagree lumping conservatives and
political non conformists together with
racists and xenophobes hey then we get
to the good part Yves Fairbanks says I
grew up in a conservative family the
people I talk to most frequently the
people I call when I need help are
conservatives I'm not inclined to paint
conservatives as thought was bigots wait
but yeah but a few years ago listening
to the voices and arguments of
commentators like Shapiro I began to
feel a very specific deja vu I couldn't
initially identify it felt as if the
arguments I was reading were eerily
familiar
I found myself googling lines from
articles especially when I read the
rhetoric of a group of people we could
call the reasonable right these are
figures who typically dislike President
Trump but often say they're being pushed
rightward
sometimes away from what they claim is
their natural leftward bent by
intolerance and extremism on the left
the reasonable right includes people
like Shapiro and radio commentator of
Dave Rubin legal scholar Amy wax and
Jordan Peterson the Canadian academic
warns about identity politics the social
psychologist Jonathan hight the New York
Times columnist Barry Weiss and the
American Enterprise Institute scholar
christina hoff sommers self-described
feminists who decry excesses in the
feminist movement the novelist Bret
Easton Ellis and the podcaster sam
harris who believed that important
subjects have needlessly been excluded
from political discussions they present
their concerns as principally freedom of
speech and diversity of thought Weiss
has called them renegade ideological
explorers who venture into dangerous
territory despite the outrage and
derision directed their way by haughty
social gatekeepers so it felt
frustrating when I read Weiss when I
listened to Shapiro when I watched
Peterson or read the supposedly
heterodox online magazine Paulette what
was I reminded of whoo I see why they
gave her this space in the Washington
Post because she was reminded of a thing
what was the thing she was reminded of
Hitler that's what she what what she's
reminded of slaveholders that's what she
was reminded of my childhood home is
just a half hour drive from the Manassas
battlefield in Virginia and I grew up
intensely fascinated by the Civil War
I loved perusing soldiers Diaries during
my senior year in college I studied
almost nothing but Abraham Lincoln
speeches well I wrote my thesis on a key
Lincoln Address Civil War
Rick was almost all I read not just that
of the sixteenth president but also that
of his adversaries thinking back on
those debates I finally figured out the
reasonable rights rhetoric is exactly
the same as the Antebellum rhetoric I'd
read so much of the same exact words the
same exact arguments rhetoric to be
precise in support of the slave-owning
South so I say that we're on the same
side cuz Nazis suck and she reads from
that I'm a neo Confederate and so is
Barry Weiss and so Jordan Peterson and
so is Jonathan Hite all of us saying why
don't we have like a conversation and
talk about stuff we're just like the
people who decided to fight a civil war
to secede from the United States while
enslaving millions of black people
exactly the same the same guys cuz
you're crazy cuz you you're
proving my point
my whole point is that you are
separating America by calling me a slave
holder by by likening me to a neo
Confederates you are separating America
that was my entire argument and your
responses but aren't you though but
aren't you a neo Confederate okay
seriously seriously she says if it
sounds absurd Shapira and his
compatriots aren't defending slavery
after all it may actually be because
many Americans are unfamiliar with the
South's actual rhetoric when I was a kid
in public school I learned the arguments
of Senator John Calhoun who called
slavery a positive good and Alexander
Stevens the Confederacy's vice president
who declared that the South's
ideological cornerstone rested upon the
great truth that the Negro is not evil
equal to the white man but such clear
statements were not the norm pro-slavery
rhetorician stuck liberal of slavery
itself instead they anointed themselves
the defenders of reason of free speech
and civility this is such unbelievable
horse bleep hey you know who else called
themselves defenders of Reason free
speech and civility abolitionists hey
everyone was many people talk this way
why because sometimes conversation is a
good thing like if she studied he period
the Lincoln the antebellum south and the
antebellum north if she's talking about
that period you know it was one of the
things that happened there was this
thing I hate to remind her called the
lincoln-douglas debates where they had a
conversation about slavery and you know
when things went wrong when people
started
the crap out of each other with canes on
the floor of the Senate when people
started firing on each other when a
whole group of people were enslaving a
whole other group of people that was the
big problem not the conversation guys
not the conversation hey that was the
problem the war had to be fought because
some people were holding other people in
bondage and they weren't going to give
up those people who were in bondage
without using violence hey that is not
reason and civility on the part of the
south that's holding people in bondage
do you not know what slavery is you
stupid ass she says it might sound
strange that America's pro-slavery
faction styled itself the guardians of
freedom and minority rights and yet it
did in a deep study of Antebellum
southern rhetoric patricia roberts
miller a professor of rhetoric at the
university of texas at austin
characterizes the story that pro-slavery
writers wanted to tell between 1830s and
1860s as not one of demanding more power
but of david' resisting Goliath they
stressed the importance of logic facts
truth science and nature much more than
northern rhetorician x' did um does she
have any like anything to back this up
at all she says they tried it their
adversary and also does that make it
inherently bad to talk about logic facts
truth science in nature again this is
the this is the problem she's saying
some people use these arguments in bad
ways they use these words and pad ways
therefore the very use of the word is
bad
what ace I mean I can see why she
doesn't like logic I can see why she
doesn't like facts or truth because they
cut really strongly against her argument
she says they love type her believe
events were the most extraordinary
spectacles that had ever challenged the
notice of the civilized world to
alarming and threatened to destroy all
that is valuable and beautiful in the
institutions of our country all over
they saw slippery slopes this argument
is literally a is is a hyperbolic
slippery slope argument her entire
argument is that if you have a
conversation with me you end up a neo
Confederate her argument is that I and
Jordan Peterson and Jonathan hight are
all neo Confederates which is about as
hyperbolic as it gets
this is all insane and self-defeating of
course she says all of there all of this
is there in the reasonable right the
claim that there
the little people struggling against
prevailing winds the argument they're
the ones championing reason and common
sense the allegation that their
interlocutors aren't so much wrong as
his as excessive they're just trying to
think freely and are being tormented the
reliance on hyperbole and slippery
slopes to warn about their adversaries
intentions and powers the depiction of
their orbit ponens as an orthodoxy an
epithet the antebellum South loved okay
she is literally making the exact
opposite argument of the argument she
thinks she's making so she's saying that
all of this sort of rhetoric is unique
to the south and also to the reasonable
right she is literally making that
argument about the right in this article
it's it like everything that she says
was the rhetoric of the antebellum South
is exactly the sort of rhetoric she is
using in the article itself about her
own enemies she says in ben shapiro who
has scribes right-wing anger to unwise
left-wing provocation i hear a letter
printed in the Charleston mercury which
warned that if the mad career of the
hot-headed abolitionists should lead to
acts of violence on the part of those
whom they so vindictively assail who
shall be accountable not the south oh
really is that what you hear really that
that's that's where you get that good
good for you lady and then she goes on
to talk about how we're not victims
right I'm not a victim the right is I've
never claimed that the right is a victim
I have said that the left-wing argument
that everyone on the right lacks
character is a nasty crap argument and
that this article is garbage right that
her entire perspective on the character
of her opponents is malign that it is
terrible for the country then it
prevents exactly the sort of political
debate we need to function as a republic
and she says is it true that it's
career-ending to be of the reasonable
right Shapiro's recent the right side of
history was in new york times number one
bestseller yes you know why not because
of CNN not because of the New York Times
not cuz of the Washington Post but
because you have excised more than half
the country by calling them racist
sexist bigots and homophobes so when I
write a book that explicitly two rides
sectionalism and tribalism and
factionalism that explicitly rips on
white supremacy multiple times there's a
big audience for it it's it
this article is insane but don't worry
there's another insane article if you
don't like that one I have another
insane article for you
get to it in just one second first let's
talk about finding the people on your
staff so I'll be honest with you I have
one good producer and one good producer
only her name is Rebecca she's the only
serious person who's ever in the room
for our shows all of my other producers
they're good at what they job but at
their job like half the time and then on
Friday they insist on wearing Hawaiian
shirts it's very bizarre well if you're
looking to upgrade your staff what you
actually need is zip recruiter com
zip recruiters comm slash daily wire in
fact zip recruiter sends your job
posting to over 100 of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there as
applications come in zip require
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly wir a zipper career.com slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire honestly everybody
here is fairly good and we're constantly
adding new producers we're constantly
hiring and that's why we do use zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire but I
want everybody except Rebecca to know
their job is not safe so zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire once again zip
recruiters comm slash Dai ly w ir e
rebecca drew the short straw on that ad
today so so Rebecca's wearing a Hawaiian
shirt today oh that totally undercuts my
the premise of that ad rate in any case
back to this article from the Washington
Post I love this they say many
reasonable right figures find themselves
defending the liberties of people to the
right of them not because they agree
with those people they say but on
principle who they have principles you
know who else had principles hmm boy
this was Hitler Hitler had principles
like what the Sam Harris a popular
podcast host has released three length
lengthy shows about charles murray a
political scientist was often booed at
campus speeches and whose 2017 talk at
Middlebury College ended when students
injured his host Murray argues that
white people test higher than black
people on every known test of cognitive
ability and that these differences in
capacity predict white people's
predominance well actually that's not
exactly what charles murray argues and
if you read his books what you would
recognize is that he explicitly says
that IQ differentials among races are at
least largely not due to genetics he
says we don't actually know what IQ
differentials based on race are based on
there is malleability in IQ not total
malleability but some malleability and
IQ it could be environment it could be
nutrition it could be a variety of
factors could be environmental it could
be genetic
he doesn't know okay that's what Charles
Murray says but Sam Harris's point is we
actually have to investigate science and
then use the best data available when we
make arguments and she's saying that sam
harris defending charles murray on the
basis of we need to investigate science
means that sam harris is a neo
confederate she says Harris's claim is
implausible hundreds of scientists
produce controversial work in the fields
of race demographics and inequality only
one though is the social scientist
nationally notorious for suggesting that
white people are innately smarter than
people of color well because he wrote a
best-selling book on IQ that would be
the why right there but apparently she
says because harris chooses to invite
this one on his show suggests he is not
merely motivated by freedom of speech it
suggests he is interested in what murray
has to say oh he's interested in a
social scientist examining data wow that
means that he's a neil confederate
racist obviously so much neil
confederate racism racism racism
everywhere so again this piece started
by pointing out that i had suggested
that we're all on the same side against
white supremacy and that it is bad for
the left to declare everyone a white
supremacist because that separates us
artificially and her response is you
know who would say that white
supremacists well done washington post
you stupid man i want to curse like dave
chappelle here you stupid m efforts i
mean oh hey really you guys are just
terrible at your jobs but we're not done
so that was i told you there were two
editorials in the washington post that
was only one of them i got another one
for you hey you ready this one is just
as good it turns out you know aside from
reasonable conversation being bad also
debate is bad debate is also bad so this
article is by donna zuckerberg a silicon
valley-based classics scholar and the
author of not all dead white men now
great she says the problems with online
to bait me culture she's anyone who
regularly expresses ideas on the
internet especially women who express
ideas critical of men has encountered
that bane of online discourse the man
who appear seemingly out of nowhere to
insist on a debate hmm
scary men wanting to bait catcalling is
aoc would put it because as we all know
the most vicious form of sexual abuse
and harassment is to say let's have a
serious talk about marginal tax rates
that's how I hit on my wife by the way
that's how it first got started she was
walking about like why not talk about
some top marginal tax rates I'd cut your
capital gains taxes let me tell you that
wanted to bait the death penalty that
actually did happen on our second date
in any case case this idiotic Washington
Post column the second one again on the
same day they're so good at their jobs
they say a classic example him a few
weeks ago after barstool sports founder
and president Dave portly threatened on
Twitter to fire his workers if they
tried to unionize after Representative
AOC joined the chorus of critics
suggesting that such threats violated
labor law Portnoy fired back
hey OC welcome to Thunderdome debate me
she ignored the request and in a
follow-up tweet he naturally suggested
that she had run from the challenge like
a terrified child apparently he's the
bad guy so she attacks his business
suggested he's a criminal
he says fine let's have a debate over it
he's very evil he initiated this you see
she yelled at him then he was going to
go to jail and then he was like okay
let's debate about this and what a bad
man he is very bad but he's not the only
bad man and this is where I come in
Ocasio Cortez is a popular target of
debate me dudes who can be high-profile
media figures or non entities in August
2018 the radio host and daily wire
editor-in-chief ben shapiro offered her
ten grand to argue with him in a public
forum well actually I offered her ten
grand to appear on the Sunday special
which is anyone who has ever watched the
Sunday special recognizes is not
actually a debate forum it's actually a
discussion forum I know the left doesn't
know the difference she refused likening
the challenge to a cat call unworthy of
her response because that's me I am
famous for my cat calls the Orthodox Jew
who slept with one woman in his life
after he was married that's my thing I
can't call women all the time
ask around the office man it is me I am
just that's that's all in fact I just
hire women so I can cat call him that's
that's like Mitt Romney I have a binder
full of them hey Shapiro has long made
to bait me part of his public persona
sense nonsense I've debated a
multiplicity of left-wing finger figures
ranging from Piers Morgan on guns on CNN
to tranq Eiger over at politican I've
challenged I believe precisely two
people to debate ever one was a OC when
it became clear that she was the fresh
face so fresh so face of the Democratic
Party the other was bony Sanders was a
man as it turns out so it's not sexual
harassment because number one I was not
sexually harassing AOC at number two I
certainly would never harass sexually
harass Bernie Sanders that seems weird
in a variety of ways this is targeting
both men and women although he himself
has ignored debate requests yes that's
true I have ignored many debate requests
because again you know what happens in a
free country
people challenge each other to debates
some people say no some people say yes
this is not a bad thing but according to
this article in The Washington Post it's
a very very bad thing a very evil and
very bad thing and you know who is the
worst here's where the article gets
spectacularly great you know who is the
worst when it came to debate me culture
and wanting to bait people Socrates
Socrates is cancelled I'm not kidding
that's where this classic scholar goes
apparently they were right to hemlock
that old bastard you know Washington
Post man they are great at their jobs
over at the editorial page we'll get
some more of this stupidity in just one
second first let's talk about going to a
post office oh the truth is I kind of
like the post office but it takes a lot
of time to get there to get back I have
to spend money on gas I have to wait in
line why would I do any of that stuff
I'll be frank with you I am lazy and I
like to do stuff from my computer if you
are like me and you are also lazy and
like you save money and do stuff from
your computer you should be using stamps
calm stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps.com can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just hand it to your mail
carrier or you drop it in a mailbox it
is indeed that simple stamps calm is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm
stamps calm again you know save yourself
a lot of time
a lot of money I don't like going to the
post office anymore because it's so much
easier to do it right here and right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that is
stamps comm enter Shapiro as your code
alrighty so we're gonna get to more from
the illustrious Washington Post
editorial page in just one second
Socrates guys is cancelled
Socrates I'm sorry to inform you that
several thousand years after his death
he has now been cancelled and it turns
out that they were right to demand his
suicide according to this columnist for
The Washington Post because I once said
that AOC should discuss politics with me
and so did Dave Portnoy which is bad
can't do that get some more of that in
just one second first you need to go
over and subscribe over at daily where I
come why should you do this thing you
should do this thing because canceled
culture is coming for everyone including
for this show but you help protect us by
becoming subscribers we are growing by
leaps and bounds our team and you should
join up also because you get all sorts
of goodies for example you get our
Sunday special on Saturdays which is
pretty spectacular so you should go
check it out do we have a clip from this
week's Sunday special
ok so let's play that thing everything
that the left is trying to do is a
threats to who we are as the nation
everything that we are built on all the
principles that were built on is on the
line when it comes to the policies that
the radical left is putting forward and
if we don't stop those the next
generation our children and our
grandchildren aren't going to know the
same America that we have you to
recognize that voice that is indeed Liz
wheeler it's a good far ranging
conversation on politics we disagree
about Trump and his tweets she's a big
fan as you know I am a little more
divided on that question but the
discussion is really good you get that
early when you become a subscriber you
also get all sorts of great stuff behind
the paywall and it is that glorious time
of the week when I give a shout out to a
new Daily wire subscriber today it is
Hunter Knox on Instagram who clearly
respects our show enough to dress up for
viewings in the picture Hunter a
handsome German Shepherd sits at the
coffee table donning a fantastic
American flag bow tie an elite beverage
vessel at the ready right next to a
laptop emblazoned with Ted Cruz for
Senate and taxation is theft stickers
that is one smart dog good doggy the
caption reads hunter wakes me up in the
to get to one get fed to get let out 3
watch the ben shapiro show
we can't wait for daily wire to move to
the best country in the united states
hashtag leftist ears tumblr hashtag
tough as texas texas truly is a
fantastic place and that is a
spectacular dog great picture and thank
you for sharing you too can be featured
or your pet can be featured over but if
you have a pet as we have already
discussed this means you're like hitler
hitler also had a dog so if you have a
pet if you have a pet and you want to
take a picture of your pet next to the
tumblr you have a great are people who
select these they really like the pets
so go check that out right now at
leftist here's tumblr also more good
news for you the daily wire has turned
four years old as a thank you to our
fans we are giving away one month of our
premium monthly subscription to anyone
who uses the code birthday for all of
august as we celebrate this milestone
we've been giving away that free first
month for our new premium monthly
subscribers bad news August is over like
right now so go do it right now again
just use the code birthday time is
quickly running out there's only one day
left one day more to get this deal so
subscribe today and come join the fun
we're having such a good time
everybody's wearing Hawaiian shirts that
could be you go check us out at daily
we're calm we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say this Washington Post op-ed
continuing with us they then decide that
debate me culture you know where you say
we should like have a debate or a
discussion that's real bad and you know
who is the best example are of a person
who is constantly trying to debate
people that old bastard Socrates at jerk
you know the guy from Plato's Republic
who was one of the foundational figures
of Western civilization that guy really
bad it turns out really messed up
according to this brilliant classic
scholar donna zuckerberg in the
washington post quote as the editor of
an online publication that runs articles
about the intersections of classical
antiquity and the modern world often
from a feminist and progressive
perspective i've gotten my fair share of
debate me challenges many of these have
come after i began writing about
far-right interests in ancient greece
and rome in twenty sixteen
blocking some of my would-be adversaries
on twitter seem to just energize them
and convince them i was afraid to engage
oh poor you poor you poor baby
a call to debate may seem intellectual
even civilized in theory well-structured
and respectful debates are an ideal
opportunity to reach an audience that
isn't fixed in its views in reality
however most debate me types seem to
view them mainly as a chance to attack
their opponents credibility their model
is not Lincoln and Douglas but rather
Socrates Wow
terrible using Socrates as a model also
just to get this straight apparently
according to that you guys should like
coordinate like walk down the hall to
that other op-ed columnist cuz the other
column was saying that lincoln-douglas
debates were bad because a lot of
slaveholders wanted reasonable civil
discussion now this one is saying that
lincoln-douglas debates those were over
slavery by the way then lincoln-douglas
debates were good but Socrates was bad
so can make up your minds like which
discussions and debates are allowed from
classical literature I can you make up
your minds
she says Socrates was bad by needle he's
cancelled by needling their
interlocutors with rapid-fire questions
they aim to reveal as they see it
their opponents ignorance and stupidity
and their own superior intelligence and
logic and then she talks about how one
time a white nationalist YouTube
personality decided to appear in her
Twitter mentions and insisted that she
called the classics inherently fascist
should my actual nuanced argument is
that belong and measurement of the
classics and white supremacy both in
Nazi Germany and then the pre Civil War
American South continues to inform how
we understand the ancient Mediterranean
met its ray
and the progressive classical scholars
should discuss that legacy and confront
it it is no surprise that someone like
this whom I ignored would draw on
stoicism which has emerged as the
favorite philosophy both of corporate
executives and the far-right ah the
Stoics are cancelled Marcus Aurelius is
cancelled guys this feminist scholar
says it I guess we're done she says
these modest men also identify with
Socrates the original debate meet role
the platonic texts show Socrates pulling
any number of Athenian sins debates and
although some are eager to argue with
him others can hardly wait to escape him
by the end of the dialogue plato's you
rip thro concludes with your rip thro
insisting he has to leave while Socrates
calls after him complaining they haven't
yet figured out - nature of piety many
of the dialogues end when the
interlocutor has been bludgeoned into
submission and seems to find it easier
to agree with Socrates than continue
further every debate me man's dream
Socrates is canceled guys Socrates is
canceled it's just this is so insane is
but there is a deeper agenda ok the
deeper agenda is we can't have
discussions right that really is the
deeper agenda if you call for a
reasonable discussion it's cuz you're a
Nazi also if you say let's discuss or
debate it's because you're like Socrates
and Socrates was a pre Nazi so you're a
Nazi in other words there is no argument
to be had with you because the very the
very fact that you are asking for a
reasonable conversation shows how
unreasonable you are you saying and the
very fact that I refuse to engage with
you shows how reasonable I am on the
left because premise reinforced you're a
bad person guys and then when all of us
out here like ok well I guess we can't
have a conversation with you're like
well now you don't want have a
conversation with me you bad people you
obviously this is not good for the
country
it's actually kind of dangerous to
suggest that every one of your political
opponents actually is a white
supremacist for wanting a reasonable
conversation or that if somebody says
you know what you have a different idea
than I do let's get together and discuss
it or debate it publicly that that is
inherently an act of violent male
oppression how the hell do you think
republicanism works discussions are
inherently but this is unfortunately
becoming a thing on the left and I'll
provide you a perfect example ok so
there's a really fascinating study that
came out yesterday hey I knew about the
study a few weeks in advance cuz I
actually talked with one of the people
who helped
the study who is not on the political
right hey well this study was all about
the genetics of same-sex sexuality now
my perspective has always been that
homosexuality homosexual activity and
orientation that this was like most
human activity a combination of genetics
and environment I was never a believer
because the evidence did not support it
that your quote-unquote born this way in
a binary way meaning that genetics
determines 100% of your sexual
orientation I think for some people that
may be true I think for the broad
majority of people that is not true that
genetics interacts with environment
interacts with epigenetics and that you
come out sort of how you come out right
I mean that that's that seems like a
perfectly reasonable position given the
fact that there are already twin studies
that showed that among genetically
identical twins only half of those
genetically identical twins ended up
either both straight or both gay right
that when you had one gauge win half the
time the other twin was straight which
suggests obviously that this is not
genetically encoded the same way that
for example race would be right if you
are genetically identical one of you is
black you're genetically identical
yeah then one of you will be black right
I mean that's just the way that genetics
works okay so this new study comes out
and the new study basically suggests
that this stuff is kind of nuanced just
like most things in life and this should
not be particularly controversial
frankly this should not be like a big
deal because what exactly does it
undermine I mean is it the suggestion
now that we should now prosecute people
again for homosexual activity like that
that doesn't undermine the libertarian
argument that if you're doing something
consensual that doesn't harm anybody
else you should be able to do what you
want but the left is very unhappy about
this study very very unhappy so what
does the study say well there's an op-ed
about it by Stephen Phelps and Robert we
Dowe Phelps's biologists we tau is a
sociologist and geneticist in the newer
times and here is what the study found
says a study published Thursday in
science looked at DNA and sexual
behavior of nearly 500,000 people it
found that the sex of your sexual
partners is in fact influenced by your
genes but it also found it was not
possible to predict your sexual behavior
from your DNA alone the study suggested
in other words that biology shapes our
most intimate selves but it does so in
tandem with our personal histories with
the idiosyncratic selves that unfold in
the larger cultural and social context
the researchers who included one of us
dr. we Dowe analyzed the genetic
occurs of people who responded to the
question have you ever had sex with
someone of the same sex from these data
the researchers estimated that genetic
differences accounts for roughly one
third of the variation in same-sex
behavior okay so not an extraordinarily
high percentage not like eighty percent
it's not ninety percent it's like a
third and as the study actually says
somewhere between eight percent and
twenty five percent
the study also identified several DNA
sequence variants associated with having
had a same sex experience in other words
there's not a gene that turns on and
says okay now you're gay or not you're
straight instead there are genes that
are that range from associations with
more risky sexual behavior to to sort of
a certain level of fluidity in terms of
sexual desire again all of this is
nuanced which is fine science can be
nuanced right so yes your sex life is
influenced by your genes now again I'm
not sure who's arguing your sex life is
not influenced by your genes I mean I
think that again as biological entities
it would be bizarre if your sex life was
not influenced by your genes at all the
entire binary argument that either you
are born 100% this way or you're born
100% not this way and you just choose to
be gay or something I always thought
that was a dumb argument and a waste of
time this conclusion fits with our
personal experiences and intuitions
sexual desire is typically stable
something we are often are aware of from
our first longings furthermore one of
these several DNA variants identified in
Thursday study is involved in gonads
development which accords with previous
research that links sexual orientation
to hormone exposure but the study's
findings also complicate the
relationship between genetics and
sexuality for one thing the results make
clear there's no single biology of
sexual behavior it turns out for example
that the genes influencing same-sex
behavior and females are often different
from those that shape behaviors and
males okay it also turns out that the
genes associated with having occasional
same-sex experiences are unlinked to
having exclusively same sex experiences
so in other words people who are
bisexual have a different genetic
profile than people who are exclusively
homosexual or people who consider
themselves straight but have strayed
into same-sex territory briefly have a
different genetic profile than people
who exclusively are interested in
same-sex experiences in addition people
who only occasionally have same-sex
partners tend to have genetic variants
associated with having more sexual
partners overall and with personality
traits like openness to new experience
which makes perfect
again if you are a person who is
experimenting you would imagine that
your genetic profile would probably be
more risk seeking right in contrast the
study found that exclusively same-sex
behavior had little correlation with the
biology of personality for some people
same-sex behavior may be a form of
exploration for many others it is not
okay so this seems like a study that is
interesting it does give the why to the
Lady gaga
baby I'm born this way therefore I have
no influence over my human behavior a
kind of stuff but it doesn't undercut
any of the arguments for its same-sex
civil rights for example it doesn't
undercut the libertarian argument again
the non harm Janice mill principle John
Stuart Mill principle that you should be
able to do what you want so long as
you're not hitting me in the nose right
what it does do is it undercuts one of
the key arguments that the left has been
holding for 40 years and that is not
true
by evidence and that argument is again
that sexual orientation is just as
genetically encoded as race in just as
binary away and the sexual orientation
is just as immutable as race which again
was fairly obviously not true because
what we have seen generationally is vast
changes in sexual behavior and I'm not
even talking homosexual or bisexual
versus straight I'm talking even within
straight communities you've seen vastly
more sexual partners over the last 40
years hey was that genetically encoded
or environmental probably had something
to do with the environment we're seeing
dramatic escalation in same-sex
experimentation in recent years is that
a great shock considering how the media
has portrayed this sort of exploration
no not really
I mean the only people who who are
undercut by this argument are the folks
who suggest on the one hand that
sexuality is entirely a choice which is
not true I mean it is your drive is not
entirely a choice and the people who
suggest that sexual behavior is not at
all a choice for anyone that it is
entirely ingrained and genetically based
entirely no environmental no choice
aspect of it at all it turns out again
like most things in life this is a
nuanced topic now why is this important
well it's important number one because
it does have some public policy
ramifications so for example you are a
young person who's experiencing same-sex
desire and you don't want to experience
same-sex desire and so you go see a
psychologist to talk about that the
entire lab says waste of time
you can't do that it'll damage you it's
really bad
okay well the evidence is not
necessarily there for that when this is
why the Left likes to when it talks
about for example gay conversion therapy
they like to go to electrocuting people
which is insane and ridiculous and
horrible they're not talking about the
17 year old who's conflicted about
sexual desire and may have desires in
multiple directions and wants to talk to
somebody about it right but more than
that the reason that this is relevant is
because there is a push by the left to
shut down this study and so the New York
Times is a piece today called many genes
influence same-sex sexuality not a
single gay gene the piece is by pam
bellick and benjamin nila geneticists at
the Broad Institute of MIT and Harvard
one of the lead researchers he said I
hope the science can be used to educate
people a little bit more about how
natural and normal same-sex behavior is
now again natural and normal does not
mean moral in the traditional religious
sense because lots of people have lots
of desires that does not necessarily
mean that fulfilling those desires in
action is not sinful but sure I mean if
you want to say genetically normal that
at least it is genetically based with
certain extent of course that's true
homosexual activity exists in the animal
kingdom as well
Benjamin Neill says it's written into
our genes and it's part of our
environment this is part of our species
it's part of who we are okay that's fine
in that again I don't really see the
problem with that but there is a problem
with the study and it's the left
objecting even before its publication
Thursday in the journal Science the
study has generated debate and concern
including within the renowned broad
Institute itself several scientists who
are part of the LGBTQ community said
they were worried the findings could
give ammunition to people who seek to
use science to bolster biases and
discrimination against gay people in
other words shut down the science
because it might not receive the result
we want if the results had been that
there is one gauging and that sexual
orientation is immutable unchanging and
entirely genetically based not entirely
environmental then you release the
findings but if it cuts against that
then you can't release the findings cuz
it undercuts our argument here's an idea
have a better argument there are plenty
of good arguments for same-sex civil
rights I've made a bunch of libertarian
arguments on that basis I think that
those are perfectly valid arguments
they're worthy of debate and
disagreement but if you're basing your
bad arguments on bad science maybe you
should change your argument instead of
trying to shut down the
science okay but unfortunately this is
the tendency of a lot of people on the
left no debate no discussion whenever
things get dicey for your arguments you
just try and shut it down shut that
stuff down
cancel it Stephen Riley geneticist and
post doctoral researcher who's on the
steering committee of the Institute's
LGBTQ affinity group said quote I deeply
disagree about publishing this it seems
like something that could easily be
misconstrued in a world without any
discrimination understanding human
behavior is a noble goal but we don't
live in that world in other words the
narrative should trump science this is
not a scientist is a political activist
and the whole goal of science is to
achieve objective verifiable facts about
the world so that we can operate within
those facts and you can still pursue
exactly the same agenda that you are
pursuing Stephen Riley but maybe your
arguments have to suck less maybe your
arguments should be based on I don't
know the science since you are in fact a
geneticist discussions between dr.
Neil's team and colleagues who
questioned the research continued for
months dr. Neil said the team which
included psychologists and sociologists
used suggestions from those colleagues
and outside LGBTQ groups to clarify
wording and highlight caveats that's
amazing so they were pre-screening the
results with activist groups can you
imagine this happening on the right can
you imagine it truly pre-screening
scientific results with advocacy groups
for a particular political narrative
this is insanity it truly is and we're
seeing this happen more and more broadly
if they're doing it in science they will
certainly do it in politics they'll do
it anywhere right dr. Neil is gay okay
dr. Neil who's one of the leads on the
study is gay he said I definitely heard
from people who are kind of why do this
at all and so there was some resistance
there personally I'm so concerned it's
gonna be deliberately misused to advance
agendas of hate but I do believe that
the sort of proactive way we've
approached this and a lot of the
community engagement aspects that we've
tried were important the moment the
study was published online Thursday
afternoon the Broad Institute took the
unusual step of posting essays by dr.
Reilly and others who raised questions
about the ethics science and social
implications of the project Joe Vidia
postdoctoral researcher at the Broad
Institute said quote as a queer person
and a geneticist I struggled to
understand the motivations behind a
genome-wide Association study for non
heterosexual behavior I have yet to see
a compelling argument
that the potential benefits of this
study outweigh its potential harms since
when is the study of science about the
potential benefits versus the potential
harms it really there is a solid case to
be made in the 1850s by every religious
person across the world that the
potential benefits of discovering
evolutionary biology outweighed that the
the harms outweighed the benefits should
that have shut down the study of
evolutionary biology in no way should
that have happened but this is the left
censorious nasty attempting to shut down
debate in dramatic ways pretty
incredible
again that study does not undermine any
of the case for same-sex rights at all
on a libertarian basis but you can't
make the argument the same way you were
making it before so change your argument
guys don't shut down the science and now
it becomes if you even discuss this
stuff publicly then you will be talked
about as a neo Confederate because after
all discussing things publicly is we
have learned makes you a Nazi
unbelievable stuff okay time for some
things I like and then it quick thing
that I hate so things that I like my
wife and I have been going through all
the old Alfred Hitchcock movies and so
the other night we watched a vertigo
vertigo has become sort of a it's it's
become a fascinating piece because so
many people I think over ate this film
some people rate this the best film ever
made I don't see that at all it
certainly got some creativity to the
direction of it Jimmy Stewart is great
in it Jimmy Stewart is a really
underrated actor just as an actor um but
the film is good and interesting it is
very slow if you watch a lot of
Hitchcock's older films they tend to be
pretty slow here is a little bit of the
trailer for vertigo which still is
enjoyable vertical a feeling of
dizziness a swimming in the head
figuratively a state in which all things
seem to be engulfed in a whirlpool of
Terror as created by Alfred Hitchcock in
the story that gives new meaning to the
word suspend
[Applause]
[Music]
all of the all of the old previews are
so cheesy and wonderful so you should go
check out vertigo if you have time also
I'll give you a preview of next week's
things I like if you have time over the
weekend go watch Dave Chappelle's
special because whoa cannot believe that
dude got away with saying that stuff
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so I'll tell you a thing that drives me
absolutely up a wall and that is
corporate virtue signaling so one of the
new things is that corporations first of
all capitalism always wins right
capitalism always wins because the
capitalists are going to find a way to
profit off of your own desire to virtue
signal so do you really think that
Cadbury chocolate is involved in the
anti-racism fight like who thought who
looked at the chocolate bar and they're
like this chocolate bar seems like it
doesn't care about racism enough who
does that exactly
okay so Cadbury has now pushed what they
call the unity bar the unity bar which
like what are we gonna have I'm waiting
for rockauto.com
to engage in racial statements about
like mufflers well why would you expect
your corporations to engage in political
statements about I think we can all
fairly assume the Cadbury opposes racism
since pretty much everybody does who is
of good heart and I have no reason to
suggest that the Cadbury like the old
kind of eggs the chocolate eggs that
those suggest some deep dark plot
against black people in any case Cadbury
pushes the unity bar in India and we
have a little bit of their their ad for
this
it says India's first charm chocolate
dark blended milk white it's a bar that
has United in one bar United in one bar
amazing the unity bar guys you Navarre
there are a couple of problems with this
bar made to celebrate India and her
people because sweet things happen when
we unite a couple problems with this the
bar segregated so there should look at
the all of all of the squares are in
their proper place it didn't mix it all
and swirl it all into one melting pot of
chocolate nope yeah the dark chocolate
on the opposite end of the white
chocolate they can't come anywhere near
each other they are separated
dramatically by race if their unity bar
was kind of a fail also it is amazing to
me if you are buying your products based
on the virtue signaling of your
corporate of the corporations that push
this sort of stuff you're an idiot if
you really believe that Nike cares about
Colin Kaepernick kneeling your hey
Nike I don't care about Nike let's sell
you shoes if you really think that
Cadbury is like sitting in the back
office going how do we fight racism
today I know the unity bar as opposed to
a lot of people out there keep talking
about this racism thing you don't be a
viral marketing campaign if we did
something about racism which do you
think is more accurate but hella yo to
buy a chocolate bar X it makes you feel
good about yourself but I getting all
fat enjoy yourself
alright we'll be back here a little bit
later today for two additional hours of
content otherwise we will see you here
on Monday what we won't actually forget
it I'm not seeing you here on Monday
we'll see you here on Tuesday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 on the mat wall show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you